The wall was a worldwide symbol:
an inhuman barrier separating the Europe of freedom
from the Europe of dictatorship,
and separating people who belong together.
Today we look at Berlin with hope.
In East Berlin and in East Germany,
the East German people’s desire for freedom
as peacefully overcome the wall and the barbed wire.
After almost three decades of separation,
Germans have been able to celebrate being reunited
and together once again.
All of us these days
are feeling that events happening in Europe,
especially in central, eastern and southeastern Europe,
are of historic importance.
For the first time since the end of the Second World War,
there is hope of overcoming East-West conflict,
of lasting stability in common freedom for all of Europe.
The division of Germany has always been
a visible and particularly painful expression
of the division of Europe.
Meanwhile, the unity of Germany will only be achieved
if the unity of our old continent progresses.
The building of a united Europe
is above all else a work of peace.
And we have to do this together.
Because we rely on the same strength
when it comes to our vision of a European peace order.
Wherever borders are crossed unhindered,
where ideas and opinions are freely exchanged,
where people can come together,
distrust and hatred, enmity have no chance in the long run.
That’s true for us West Germans,
it’s also the case for East Germans.
It’s not just their liberty which is at stake,
but that of Poles and Hungarians,
along with the future of people in the Soviet Union.
Czechs and Slovaks, Bulgarians and Romanians.
It is about the freedom of one Europe.